soyez les bienvenus à cette nouvelle
émission facebook live d'ici espace
autochtone en direct beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui autour de la table parce que
c'est une journée spéciale
d'abord il ya la nuit des sans abri nous
allons en parler avec vous monsieur
gaudreault pierre gaudreau bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur du rapsim
alors juste rapidement leurs racines
fait quoi leur absence le réseau des
deux personnes seules et itinérantes
morgan regroupement de sang neuf
organismes qui viennent en aide aux gens
qui sont dans la rue un risque de l'être
et les centres de jour des refuges des
projets de logement des ressources et
des gens accueilli beaucoup
d'autochtones de plus en plus
malheureusement aux lèvres et nous
allons parler d'eux alors avec chalon
bat contre la personne bonjour charge
dont nous allons parler cette fois ci
des comédiens autochtones vous êtes un
comédien vous allez pouvoir parler de
votre réalité exactement je vais je vais
vous expliquer un peu qu'est ce qu'elle
est resté dedans d'un comédien
autochtone vous expliquer un peu le type
de casting de de casting peut avoir un
autochtone avec est bon le métissage
oui les rôles qu'on lui donne des rôles
pour lui donne pas exane a exactement et
puis enfin la salle bonjour anne
journaliste à l'émission enquête à la
télévision de radio canada
alors vous faites de la télé mais vous
faites aussi du podcast maintenant
d'abel ado c'est une première oui une
série balade au chemin de croix huit
épisodes mais c'est nouveau pour moi
c'est nouveau mais c'est fort absolument
et puis nous irons aussi du côté de
trois-rivières parce que maintenant les
communautés atikamekw du nord du québec
reçoivent radio canada en français vous
savez pendant longtemps c'était
desservies par 6 bis in world
donc ils recevaient des émissions en
cris mais les attikameks ne parle pas en
général de grippe depuis le comprennent
ne parlez pas alors voilà maintenant
donc des émissions de radio canada de la
radio de radio canada sont offertes aux
populations aux trois communauté
attikamek du québec donc nous allons en
parler avec la directrice de radio
canada d'abord pierre gaudreau donc
c'est cette nuit la nuit des sans abri
oui c'est nous qui veut dire une 29e
nuit des sans-abri ou on attire
l'attention c'est quelque chose qui est
né à montréal modestement à l'époque on
parlait juste de la nuit des jeunes sans
abri
et maintenant cette estime dans une
quarantaine de villes dans presque
toutes les régions du québec
ce soir à partir de la fin d'après midi
et les gens se rassemblent
différentes activités sont organisées
pour attirer l'attention sur la route et
l'itinérance en dehors de montréal on en
parle peu mais cela me existe il
pourrait essayer aussi d'interpeller les
gouvernements et l'on en a un nouveau
pour qu'ils aient davantage d'actions
soit menée pour contrer le phénomène et
les populations les plus importantes
dans la rue ce sont les autochtones à
montréal malheureusement d'événements
real oui on est à la 29e édition de la
nuit des sans abri
il y eut une trentaine d'animaux le
réseau des personnes itinérantes on
existe depuis quarante cinq ans il y en
avait peu contrairement à d'autres
villes canadiennes moyen de hollow bara
tall
il y avait du sens de l'équité
autochtonie desjoyeaux longtemps way
toronto un peu aussi évidemment dans les
villes de l'ouest du canada
la situation à montréal malheureusement
se développe au niveau de l'excellence
autochtone tour elle avec l'arrivée du
container
on a vu davantage de gens ne vit
davantage de ressources développée pour
répondre aux besoins mais définitivement
pas assez donc il des gens qui arrivent
à montréal il tombe à la rue et c'est ce
que j'allais vous dit rien pas beaucoup
de ressources pour les autochtones quand
on regarde dans la liste du réseau il ya
deux trois services pour les autochtones
ya pas qu évidemment projets autochtones
du québec je pense que les plus
importants il ya chez doris parce que
les femmes peuvent aller chez doris ma
part sa une le foyer des femmes
autochtones qui est plus de
l'hébergement comme walter 1100 m2 cet
automne qui accueille kingson deux jours
que les 42 jours depuis que des
patrouilles de rue oui il ya d'autres
organismes aussi qui accueille oui mais
avec toutes les difficultés
kill you de pour accueillir correctement
culturellement adaptés il ya beaucoup de
barrières à l'accès et dans bien des cas
les autochtones ne voudront pas aller
dans certaines ressources c'est moi ce
que je pense parce que il n'ya pas
quelqu'un qui quitte banques sont pas
nécessairement qu'ils ont pas
nécessairement de difficultés arrivent à
montréal mais la difficulté vient de se
trouver un logement de devoir de trouver
du travail avait intégré la société donc
ces difficultés là je pense lesquelles
chaque autochtone pays manque beaucoup
d'organismes pour accompagner ces gens
là il ya beaucoup trop d'organismes de
première ligne qui passait pour
l'accompagnement des gens d'en bas dans
leur étape où sont rendus tes dents ou
six ans dans le vide donc c'est ce que
je suis pour un peu qui manque dans la
vie le manga c'est le ddd organise tout
ce que sait on accompagne la deuxième
ligne mais la première ligne c'est déjà
de se trouver un logement exactement un
endroit pour dormir la nuit et elle est
là la plus grande des difficultés les
l'homme je suis tout à fait d'accord qui
manque de ressources dans deux mines
favoriser la sortie de situation
d'itinérance éveillé et la prévenir ou
c'est ça avec un accompagnement
un accueil qui soit adaptée
définitivement au niveau des ressources
ya un manque de ressources d'hébergement
de première ligne quand j'étais tendu
québec fait un bon travail mais encore
l'eau parfois les gens vont préférer la
rue mais vont pouvoir se retrouver entre
eux alain eu dans certains cas oui il ya
le toit rouge qui tourne à la place des
arts une église qui quitte une halte
chaleur l'hiver qui est très fréquentée
par des autochtones et qui accueille
encore là seulement le jour oui et la
nuit l'hiver comme al chara et depuis
l'hiver dernier où va la toute l'île
après mandat température skis très bien
et au point d'orgue ce qui était dans
l'ouest entre des titres centre de jour
et beaucoup cet automne kg est à se
relocaliser dans
dans le sud ouest du plateau mais qui
est un peu de difficulté non bassaletti
de ces lieux un peu de remous mais
effectivement il ya eu du pas dans ma
cour mais souvent les médias vont mettre
la tension sur le programme court ont
levé aussi sur le sort des injections
supervisées ça prend de 3 personnes qui
gueule fort et et quelques médias qui en
parlent beaucoup qui on a l'impression
qu'il ya globalement pas d'en bas coûts
qu'on avait beaucoup dans le plateau si
c'est autant de nouveau des élus des
organismes des citoyens et citoyennes du
monde qui veulent que le qu'elle
organise swallow passe tu vois les gens
parce que ce sont surtout des premières
nations des inuits
moi j'aime beaucoup des nouettes
énormément de notes
il ya beaucoup de ça doit être selon les
quartiers au centre ville les données
qu'on a que sont partiales évidemment
parce que donner c'est les données des
gens qui fréquentent et ressources
fréquentent pas les ressources suis allé
donner une suite des nombreux modes de
week-end il y avait quand même dans la
composition ou autochtone une bonne
version
en termes de provenance des différentes
nations mais effectivement contre
valence love 2008 surtout à la rue et on
parle de chez deyris peter lord moyens
c'est des jeunes des adultes et des gens
à diouloulou son convoi jusqu'à les gens
tous les ans j'ai beaucoup
les jeunes dans le moyen de gamme déjà
qu'on voit à la rue et est en très
grande difficulté est là on est en train
de se développer des services pour
l'ensemble de population mais qui
doivent aussi être capable d'apporter
des réponses aux autochtones des
services qu'on appelle en anglais des
oueds soul ii soul la consommation plus
est permise parce que on se met à
l'extérieur c'est très dangereux ou
interne tout est remis en termes de
conditions de sevrage donc on travaille
pour que des réponses accrue soin
apporté aux gens qui sont déjà dans la
rue mais ici aussi comme vous le disiez
bien faut travailler pour les gens
tombent pas la rue est évidemment puis
on savait bien d'autres le travail plus
conditions soient là pour les gens de
vivre poney soient pas obligés de venir
à montréal à raison surpeuplement dans
les logements de ces raisons je voudrais
vous demander pourquoi il ya cette
croissance de différent des premières
nations dans l'ami certaine ce qu'on a
vu aussi dans certains cas c'est des
gens qui arrivent se faire soigner ça me
sentais encore chez les inuit pas d'eau
courante dans les communautés
pas d'eau chronique au surpeuplement
dans les logements les gens via montréal
et dans d'autres grands centres
les gens qui viennent au cpie qui
courent saint céré ou pour développer
une formation qui domine tous avant des
soins de santé et qui se retrouvent en
rupture du lien avec les milieux
académiques en rupture de 2,2
soins hospitaliers qui l'a dépendant de
la communauté qu'ils ont ici pour
pouvoir rapidement malheureusement se
retrouver à l'air du temps des
ressources alors anne vous la connaissez
la réalité vous justement peut-être pas
dans les gens dans la rue ici mais dans
les communautés comment vivent les gens
dans les communautés les difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés
mais c'est drôle parce moyenne avec top
tout ce qui me vient en tête quand
j'entends ça la croix saint léger des
ebooks qui venait à montréal
dakar entend même des gens car lorsqu'il
voyait un itinéraire mon dieu comment ça
se fait comment ça c'est que sa famille
ce qui pollue vous été étonné devant il
y avait pas d'itinérants des premières
nations mais ils étaient étonnés de voir
y avait de l'itinérance qui avait tué
ben oui et là on en voit de plus en plus
qu'andy ils n'ont pas de famille
oui on des familles mais des familles
qui ont débordé dont on connaît la
situation et mais je connais pas
tellement la situation de l'itinérance
met ce que j'aille à lise c'est que les
gens qui qui ont cliqué ont une vie dont
anormales sont souvent des gens qui sont
tombés dans la drogue dans l'itinérance
ou si certainement c'est des gens qui
ont vécu des abus sexuels
c'est des gens qui ne se relève pas
d'abus sexuels de violences sexuelles
qui fuient la moyenne sexuelle et vous
en avez rencontré je veux que le lien
entre l'abus sexuel et les suicides
également c'était lorsque l enquête du
coroner sont nés cinq suicides c'est à
dire quoi non deux ans les cinq
personnes s'étaient suicidées avait vécu
des abus sexuels et au lien direct les
femmes ne faisait son talent immense
comment les familles nous le font
spontanément et la solitude que j'ai vu
c'est celle justement d'en cas du
coroner vous avez tout à fait raison de
soulever le problème c'est ce canadien
être sur le vécu des différences dans la
vie des qualités canadien auprès trente
mille personnes en quête général
situation des ménages quelque chose
qu'ils vont montrer rigoureux et
exhaustif et c'était 7 % des femmes aux
cadeaux et 8% d'examen ont vécu un
moment de leur vie des situations
d'itinérance y cacher un moment mais
quand on regarde la prévalence de avec
une itinérance pour les autochtones pour
les gens qui sont passés par le réseau
de guillemets protection de la jeunesse
dans les gens qui ont perdu des réseaux
qui sont des médecins dont beaucoup de
conditions qui appartient mais qui sont
là l'équipe oak certaines vies qu'ils
ont vécues de biens isotopes temps on
passe à des tours de 15 à 22 25 % de
gens qui ont vécu dans une période dont
on peut trouver les périodes les poly
période mais le placement ou la preuve
l'utilisation des réseaux protection sur
son allié aussi à des agressions
sexuelles dans plusieurs cas et pas
toujours appropriés on le sait assez
statique statistiques l'heure ces
canadiens aussi québec
canadian hydro québec de l'extraire pour
l'art que les situations se ressemblent
sont différentes c'est parce qu'on
imagine vancouver ont comme inpex et les
grandes villes de l'ouest mais on
n'imaginait pas qu'ici à montréal et à
québec c'est que ce soit la même chose
les premiers regards qu'on nous fait sur
les données québécoises de ces temps
quelqu'un des dizaines de champion
quand même beaucoup de similitudes alors
anne maintenant je me tourne vers vous
parce que je le disais vous en avez
rencontré beaucoup des gens qui ont vécu
ces situations-là qui aurait pu devenir
itinérant parce que justement leur vie
avait été démoli par le passé vous avez
rencontré beaucoup de gens et alors on
va parler de deux choses on va parler
oui d'un reportage que vous avez
présenté enquête mais aussi d'une balade
au qui raconte l'histoire de beaucoup de
gens qui ont soit perdu des enfants qui
ont disparu comme ça parce que
évidemment toute la question début on ne
fait des reportages enquêtes sur les
abus tels que les femmes avaient vécu
soit au med certains policiers de la
sûreté du québec mais aussi à l'inter
la viande et c'est souvent un effet un
propos infecté un effet domino
malheureusement des gens qui ont été
abusés devient des abuseurs
on connaissait mais dans le balade aux
huit épisodes on l'a appelé chemin de
croix mais ça débute sur une chose puis
ça finit sur l'autre milieu lien c'est
les enfants disparus de pakua shipi qui
ont été envoyés à l'hôpital de
blanc-sablon c'est une communauté en
ligne lacie petite protéine ou sur la
base convenance et la dernière
communauté ou québec près du labrador
oui qui avait envoyé des enfants
l'hôpital de blanc-sablon dans les
années soixante et onze 112 donc en très
peu de temps 18 mois neuf enfants de la
communauté ne reviennent pas de
l'hôpital et les gens ne savaient pas si
vraiment les enfants étaient décédées et
s'ils étaient les était décédé de quoi
est il est enterré ou en famille les
mêmes plusieurs des meilleurs et ont
peut-être été adoptée bon on ne
cherchait ces informations là on a
découvert que ces enfants là d'après les
archives médicales sont décédés mais ils
ont été enterrés à blanc sablon et on ne
s'explique pas pourquoi le pit à ne pas
avertir les parents pourquoi l'hôpital
ne pas renvoyer les corps encore
dernièrement j'ai parlé à un médecin qui
était dans cette région la les paul
était en comprend pas comment les corps
étaient renvoyés naicom noté blanc jouit
nous il devance collomb le préfet pour
n'ont pas averti les parents de
l'inhumation c'est quand même assez
incroyable donc resté quarante ans en
saluant son enfant est décédé monsieur
le maire je grammaire et l'on s'aperçoit
que leur lien avec les oblats alexis
genou c'est lui qui avait le téléphone
c'est lui qui aurait dû avertir les
parents et la communauté pas quoi jpy
est en rupture avec l exige nous c'était
le père genou qui étaient là dont il ya
tellement à ce moment là et qui avaient
forcé la déportation le déménagement des
gens de pas quoi j mee vers la romaine
permis lamenti poux quand même 300 km de
là et les gens certaines familles
avaient décidé de retourner à pied dans
leur terre ancestrale a pas quoi chipie
et le père joe venons les a punis et
avec le gouvernement a envoyé des
messages au gouvernement de
les aides et pas alors ces gens lire a
abandonné on les a à parthenay et c'est
à cause de cette situation l'unc les
enfants de pakua shipi n'ont pas reçu
les soins adéquats
ses cheveux une histoire mais
travaillant là dessus les attikameks
prennent contact avec moi ceux qui sont
en mauricie où maurice est bon les trois
communautés de communes nous a même
chance qu'on a perdu des enfants pensez
pas où ils sont une vingtaine de
familles cherchent leurs enfants et là
encore leur endroit on a parlé d'alexis
j'opte les femmes ont parlé des
agressions sexuelles de journaux les zsc
m'ont dit d'où le père où il faisait la
même chose
le pérou il sait exactement même changé
par les mots du père houle qui a été
agrémentée chic est à manawan et manawan
s'étaient plaints de lui auprès des
autorités les jeunes religieuses ils ont
des styles le déminage et de le sortir
de là imaginer qu'avec la beauté
s'invite chez nous le père suivre son
oeuvre pour poursuivre alors j'appelle
pas ça mais wall est ce que fait les
dommages et où on vient apporter les
réponses beaucoup il était violent et
que les enfants ont donné du coup de
pied mais archambault par exemple dont
on parle alors finalement de fil en
aiguille je trouve disent suffisamment
de témoignages pour incriminer 10 oblats
différents dans huit communautés soit du
québec soit nous qui ont été des
abuseurs
donc on commençait que les enfants
disparus le rôle des hommes là où il
aurait finalement unique les abus
sexuels mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans toute cette série l'1 ce que je
voulais surtout démontrer c'est qu'il ya
des résistants il ya des gens qui se
sont rebellés qui ont posé des questions
pour peut-être pas les réponses mais qui
ont posé des questions qui se sont
plaints des curés qui ont su retourner
sur leurs terres ancestrales dont et ce
sont des résistants
il ya des gens qui ont survécu et ont
continué à vivre qui ont contraint poser
des questions et il ya là une prise de
parole pour - qui est libératrice sont
les événements et je pense que ce soit
une histoire justice
oui et d'éviter with des horreurs métro
se demande pourquoi ça sort maintenant
c'est ça s'est passé dans les années 70
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour que ça
mais les abus sexuels sont poursuit
jusqu'en 2000 - oui dans les années 90
seulement maintenant les longues mois et
demi tout autochtone je pense vraiment
qu'il poussait parole que débuter avec
les pensionnats qu'il a avec les enfants
sont bien parler des enfants
on l'a vu quand les femmes et les hommes
sont venus aux audiences de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes autochtones
disparues à malioténam en novembre
dernier et venez parler des enfants
disparus et y ont dit mais on va aller
plus loin on veut toujours tout ce que
faisait alexis genou et c'est ça et on
parlait donc des abus sexuels de
jouvenel est censée inciter les
attikameks aussi à parler des abus
sexuels chez eux il ya des gens qui
m'ont parlé plus vieux de 75 ans accusé
est ce qu'on me dit à chaque fois je
suis content d'avoir parlé j'ai pu me
libérer de ce fardeau lot de l'abîmé du
silence qui m'ont été imposée et donc
c'est ça le silence imposé parfois par
la communauté où les animés par les
religieux réception et la prise de
parole qui a contenu toutes ces années
là et qu'il advient tellement forte
qu'on peut de que l'entente oui
absolument
et donc on l'entend dans la balado mes
galons dans votre reportage présenté qui
a été présenté jeudi soir enquête
oui je ne sois c'était que sur les abus
sexuels s'était essoufflé 10 oblats qui
ont abusé sexuellement en général
d'enfants parfois de femmes en général
c'est des enfants des gamins des
fillettes
ouais c'est 7 8 ans un vin des sables a
vu deux communautés
et aujourd'hui vous savez que le diocèse
de montréal le diocèse de québec
l'association des évêques catholiques du
québec disent oh mercy mercy enquête
ils m'ont envoyé des tweets merci
atanassoff d'avoir fait cette enquête et
on ne peut que se révolter et chercher
la vérité alors les autochtones la vie
remake et nous ont brisé le silence et
une loi ordinaire ils ont tellement
parlé fort que là les communautés sont
obligés de dire oui mais comment ces
gens là maintenant aussi parce qu'il ya
des répercussions qui auront duré tout
le recours collectif long exposé de
dirhams collective du recours collectif
est ce qu'on comprend c'est que les
houblons accepté de négocier une entente
hors cour on doit éviter aux victimes de
devoir témoigner
oui dernier ne sais pas c'est pas que
prier mais en général les gens m'ont dit
d'enfance qu'on veut sont des excuses
on veut que la congrégation des oblats
de marie immaculée reconnaissent que des
élus qui l'ont laissé faire
souvent ils savaient ils ont laissé
faire donc c'est la reconnaissance qu'il
faut parler mais il faut être entendu
bien su alors être entendus je dis oui
je reconnais le oui oui des excuses
davantage que l'argent l'argent reste
pas de problème des excuses
et puis damman s'assurer que ça se
reproduira pas c'est bien entendu mais
moi je rêve d'une enquête publique
moi j'ai ma soeur d'aller fouiller dans
les ruines oui parce que ce sera là
aussi une enquête mobile et ils l'ont
fait aux états unis dans pennsylvanie et
mon fils ils l'ont fait en irlande si on
ouvrait les livres et qu'on vous pouvez
dès à petit il savait pourtant curie
puis c'était notables on l'envoie on
trouverait beaucoup plus que dix doubles
et dans le recours collectif d'ailleurs
il ya 17 au bloc et qui sont dans la
mire parce que c'est pas seulement les i
nous repassons médicaments mais aussi
les anishinabe elie crée donc c'est
toute personne qui a été agressée
sexuellement par un membre de la
congrégation des oblats de pda docteur
nous c nous n'autorisons qui ont pris
contact
oui alors il on s'approche de 121 17 au
blanc moi je pensais pas finir sur une
vraie les niveaux bon dieu on aurait au
final ce parce que des statistiques qui
disent que 10% des prêtres sont des
abuseurs
d'après une étude de presse américaine
sociologue à l américain uaw et à 10%
des prêtres son abuseur ont été amuseurs
les oblats sont peut-être plus tellement
nombreux mets dans mes longs et ils
étaient très nombreux dans les années 50
60 70 cents dans les communautés
autochtones c'était leur mission
d'évangéliser les autochtones 10%
oui est ce que au réseau vous avez eu
les témoignages comme ça des personnes
autochtones qui ont révélé des passé
trouble comme ça dans les ressources
issues des témoignages qui sont entendus
mais louis ii
du temps que ça prendra que les gens
puissent s'ouvrir quand les gens sont
accueillis dans l'urgence ils vont
parfois parler de leur parcours mais
trop souvent le temps n'est pas les
conditions pour que la greffe et ça ça
prend une personne qui commence puis qui
dit qu'ils continuent plus authentique
pour une personne qui se plaignent 9
ça prend du temps mais ça finit par ça
finit par se finit par sortir moi je
suis trouve qu'ils sont brisés lire ils
sont vivants et c'est ça que j'aime et
s'appelle richard kistabish disait il
faudrait inventer un mot communaux mais
nous les survivants pas trop une nouveau
beau je crois que j'ai pas comment pour
qu'ils étaient vivants
vous savez vous parliez des attikameks
ils ont été aussi touché par cette
réalité
alors j'espère des abus des enfants des
taux tout et j'espère qu'ils vont
pouvoir évidemment regarder votre
reportage dans quai mais surtout écouter
votre balade n'est pas là doit vous
savez c'est l'application ici premières
pouvaient le télécharger sur votre
ordinateur sur votre tablette et six
premiers oui jamais une croix huit
épisodes si vous le faites sur votre
téléphone moi je le fais je le fais sur
le téléphone d'une application balado
louis pion aux demandes
histoire locale est en fait ça fait
partie de une série qu'on commence à
radio-canada qui s'appelle histoire au
pluriel dans le cadre du premier balade
ou par ma collègue isabelle richer sur
la sphère jolivet et moi j'arrivais avec
huit épisodes chemin de croix alors ça
se télécharge puis on écoute quand on
veut on écoute dans le dos quand on
roule entre un trou et montech et là
dessus qu'on entre cet élément comme
chez vous restez bien mémorial on les
côtes dans le métro si on habite
montréal
les gouttes d'un oui là ça serait plus
difficile écoute en se rendant jusqu'à
trois-rivières c'est là qu'on va aller
tout de suite on va les rejoindre nancy
sabourin
c'est la directrice des services
français de radio-canada mauricie centre
du québec parce que les autochtones les
attikameks bonjour madame sabourin a je
ne vous entends pas oui là je vous
entends c'est ça madame sabourin vous
allez desservir la radio de radio-canada
donc votre service à vous à trois
rivières va desservir les communautés
attikameks du québec c'est déjà fait
depuis le 17 octobre au matin
notre antenne locale mauricie centre du
québec est maintenant diffusée dans les
trois communautés atikamekw de manawan
wemotaci et obedjiwan donc à 6 heures le
17 octobre au matin
les gens pouvaient entendre notre
programmation locale on est très très
fier de ça alors qu'est ce que vous leur
présentez en fait c'est oui en fait ils
ont accès
oui effectivement ils ont accès à
l'antenne de radio canada mauricie
centre du québec et au niveau local bien
sûr il ya notre émission matinale à
trois rivières qui est facteur matinale
également notre émission d'après midi de
13h30 à 18h qui et 3,60 pm et tous nos
bulletins de nouvelles qu'on fait
l'auteur doller à tous les jours et ce 7
jours sur 7
donc les gens peuvent entendre parler de
la région parce que vous savez qu
auparavant bien sûr les communautés
autochtones avaient avaient accès à issy
première mais c'est d'une antenne de
montréal avec des détachements de la de
l'antenne de chisasibi en langue crie
alors ils les grands chefs se sont dits
attikameks se sont dit on serait peut
être mieux desservis sont avait
l'antenne locale de trois-rivières et
c'est ce qui est arrivé mercredi matin
donc siby sinon les émissions en langue
crie ne sont plus présentés alors ne
sont plus présentés puis je regardais
des statistiques qui ont été produits là
pour la demande au crtc et je voyais le
sol ont ce qu'on nous dit qu'il ya
seulement cinq personnes dans les trois
communauté attikamek qui parlent crient
[Rires]
je pense que c'était un choix logique
mais vous savez mieux que vous avez de
la compétition parce qu'elle est radios
communautaires qui marche très très fort
dans les communautés
effectivement mais je pense qu'on est
des on a des contenus complémentaires
les ils ont besoin de leurs radios
communautaires qui sont effectivement
très très ancrés dans leur milieu
avec leur langue avec leur culture mais
nous ce qu'on veut faire puis on espère
que cette nouvelle on va créer un pont
pont peu plus solide entre les
communautés autochtones et radio canada
puis on veut vraiment être davantage le
reflet de ce qu'ils sont de ce qu'ils
font est pas juste parler des problèmes
sociaux en vous savez vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir
on parle beaucoup des problèmes sur ce
que vous en parliez le juste avant qu'on
ait le début de cette conversation mais
nous on va aller un petit peu plus loin
qu'est ce que vivent ces gens là quelles
sont leurs préoccupations alors vraiment
une main tendue qu'on fait aux
communauté attikamek de ces trois
communautés l'appui on espère être à la
hauteur des attentes
donc vous allez parler avec eux vous
allez avec dans leurs communautés d être
sur le terrain aussi on l'était déjà
on le l'être encore plus si on commence
à la semaine prochaine on s'envoie toute
l'équipe de l'équipe de l'émission
d'après midi pendant soixante pm on s'en
va à la tuque
on aurait aimé aller dans une communauté
mais techniquement c'était impossible de
faire mes légendes et communauté
attikamek sont souvent gratuites alors
on sent dans la tuque faire une émission
spéciale 100% attikameks avec une
portion musicale et on est allé notre
collègue elyse allan s'en va justement à
wemotaci le mardi et mercredi prochains
allez en parler de plein de sujets de
parler je lui parlais tout à l'heure
j'ai d'élise quels sont tes sujets de
parler de compostage recyclage dans les
communauté attikamek on veut elle veut
parler des femmes qui cuisinent la bo de
façon très communautaire on veut parler
des maisons de jeunes qui ont des
projets semble-t-il absolument
formidable et on veut entendre des
artistes locaux aussi qu'on aura
d'ailleurs une portion musicale entre
autres avec loramyc oui lors de notre
édition du 25 octobre
d'accord et vous êtes on vous sait
tony's en fait si on est à manawan
wemotaci ou dans l'autre communauté on
vous sait tony's sur quelle fréquence
et pour que j'ai pas les fréquences avec
moi malheureusement je pourrais je
pourrais pas vous donner les fréquences
et je profite on a je ne les ai pas mais
je présume que les gens là bas les ont
et puis si on je pourrais vous donner
cette information peu plus tard
il ajoutera surnage d'espacé cette
spéciale sic
merci beaucoup madame sabourin versys
nous avons parlé de l'antenne de
radio-canada dans ces communautés
au revoir à journée voilà alors ça c'est
intéressant ça leur donne de
l'information en france est bon pour
tous ceux qui veulent l'écouter en
français et puis sinon dindane
attikameks pour les gens qui écoutent la
radio communautaire j'en parle parce que
c'est important
c'est très crucial les radios
communautaires dans l'éco mobilité que
le bingo
et oui oui l'autre jour j'ai fait une
entrevue avec justement une personne
comment il s'appelle elle a fait un film
pour le wapikoni mobile madame marque
elle et dans les communautés où nous
je me rappelle plus quelle communauté
mais en fait elle attend une marque
oui on a tellement l abattage est
exactement l été sur la basse-côte-nord
justement elle attendait sa soeur et
voulait que sa soeur se joignent à moi
pour l'entrevue téléphonique alors elle
a fait l'appel sur les radios
communautaires
elle est arrivée 15 minutes après le
départ des impôts ces données dans une
communauté
bon à la tuque plutôt coups et montages
chioui mochis aucun hébergement ya pas
de nom c'est hamza ses bienfaits de
réseaux cellulaires
non non pas de manawan y en avait mais
pas partout il ya quand même une aube et
georges mpaga demandé est-ce que c'est
internet haute vitesse
non non non c est ce que les maisons
vraiment tout internet est encore d'un
manque de services
oui absolument je parle même pas de
pitié s'il est l'éloignement qu'ils
fassent aussi un fax et c
s'améliore passer ces conditions là non
plus donc il faudrait trouver des
solutions qui met en contrepartie la
langue atikamekw parler par tous exact
c'est vrai oui la langue line ou le sera
de plus en plus les des cours dit nous
qui sont donnés un peu partout mais là
on va pas parler de kourdi nous avec vos
chances d'en parler vous avez quittez
vous votre communauté pour venir jouer à
mes analyses octobre parce que jouer
dans les communautés et il n'y a pas
beaucoup de travail quand même les
comédiens c'est plus restreint si on n'a
pas de saintes théâtrale on a des scènes
de musique mais moins propice pour le
théâtre c'est plus et plus et plus
restreint disant oui il faut aller
s'affilier avec les villes avoisinantes
des choses comme ça donc il ya quand
même possibilité mais c'est pas ce qu'il
ya de mieux dans oui oui il ya beaucoup
de gens qui viennent au magasin qui
viendraient s'agréger qui est bien
nécessaire d'en haut mais là on va
parler de la facilité ou de la
difficulté de travailler ici dans un
grand centre comme montréal centres
urbains
je sais que bahia comme plusieurs
catégories d'emploi quand on est
autochtone en même temps oui tu sais
comme on vous dit aussi que ton pour un
casting bon il ya plusieurs castings
différents n'ont pas tous le même
casting
donc il ya trois types moi je dis que
trois types de ces deux de trois types
de comédiens autochtones
on ne le premier qui celui qu'elle est
très physionomiques autochtone ok mais
sans âme et sans accent dans son
français donc qu'en français impeccable
le deuxième pas si moussa sow c'est moi
avait peut-être avec les très puissants
l'accent le deuxième type on parle on a
les traits physiques et io l'accent soit
d'une langue autochtone quelconques dont
on l'a on a le le pur que j'ai l'allèle
la vérité le vrai visage la vraie langue
la sonorité la façon dont ils vont
s'exprimer en français ça va être
complètement différent donc et on ne le
troisième qui est centrée physionomiques
et parle très bien français
il serait même le quatrième qu'elle ait
pas de fusionner qui parlent la langue
aussi bon qu'il y ait des gens qui n'ont
pas de l'art autochtone et oui oui à la
langue louis donc cesser ses traits
l'avons vont jouer sur le rôle que peut
jouer danser rire lequel a le plus de
chances d'avoir un rôle
las partout ça dépend vraiment du
contexte on peut parler aux côtés du
cinéma au cinéma on cherche toujours une
vérité on veut avoir si on a un texte
mais on veut qu'il soit bien compris on
en a chez de licher tour en au cinéma la
télé on essaie de rendre ce très beau
mais au théâtre par exemple une personne
qui quitte pas la physionomie puis qui
parle qui parle très bien français
pour incarner un autochtone au théâtre
c'est plus facile on dirait qu'on se
permet plus au théâtre de cette
acceptation là qui peut jouer en attaque
tandis qu'au cinéma
il est blond aux yeux bleus ça marche
pas on n'y croit pas donc ce n'est pas
un autochtone c'est vraiment cette
petite ligne là donc on fait on a des
rôles différents mais pourtant on est
tous des autochtones à quel point qu'on
devient d un post en soi même on accepte
un rôle quand qu'on accepte un rôle
est-ce que ce que je suis ce que je suis
ça est ce que je suis ce qui demande à
ce que rim est même cité autochtone est
ce que tu peux pas jouer autre chose
oui c'est logique
on devrait jouer autre chose que des
autochtones under respire ça devrait pas
être un problème
non parce que je pense que c'est
pourquoi qu'on devrait saint joseph sera
la seule personne qui m'a donné la
chance de ne pas jouer le toc toc c'est
c1 sonia pendentifs et le ballon dans
son film quand on joue des autochtones
mais on est on est pas lundi les geôles
nazies
c'est une autochtone qui vous a donné ce
oui c'est ça exactement donc on ne joue
pas lundi on est dans une réalité on le
danger dans un dans un contexte autre
que de jouer l'indien sur un cheval avec
son fusil
c'est vraiment autre chose donc très
bien ils vont parce que ccc dans
l'univers ou six sorties donc il ya eu
plusieurs plusieurs c'était comme les
comédiens on est confronté plusieurs
choses là plusieurs préjugés ouais non
c'est bien il ya deux cas mais il ya
quand même une part il ya quand même une
demande de jouer d'indiens mais ça n'est
plus valorisant que ça devient ça
devient que je ne jouis communauté ce
que je mets ce que vous voyez des
améliorations à ce que ça a tendance à
changer par exemple parce que on parle
beaucoup des autochtones maintenant il
ya bon il ya espace au total qui
existent par exemple mais il n'y a pas
juste ça il ya un homme qui parle avec
tous ces reportages on qui qui nous
ouvre à la réalité des autochtones à
mieux les comprendre
et est ce que le commun des mortels lui
comprend qu'un autochtone c'est un
canadien comme les autres et qu'il
devrait avoir sa place comme n'importe
qui dans la société tout à fait oui il
ya une certaine amélioration on voit
beaucoup sur les plateaux qui est
beaucoup plus de consultants il ya plus
de gens qui viennent qui viennent
informer la réalisation la production /
sur certains certaines techniques
certain savoir-faire autochtone dont
donc on a c'est vraiment d'aller
chercher quelque chose de plus véridique
de plus vrai de plus proche de la
culture
mais ce qui est encore lorsqu'il est
encore difficile c'est que les gens du
kin lyon ils n'ont pas cette cet
apprentissage la dé communauté des
nations
c'est que à un moment donné on va te
faire parler en a 10 km il longtemps
l'hôte lausanne après ou dans l'autre
émission dans la saison d'après on va te
faire par la marque
et pourtant tu joues le même sort
personnage c'est juste qu'ils étaient
plus dans la même région dans l'histoire
mais le titre parle d'amour dont il ya
comme un il ya comme un peu le mélange
d'un autochtone par toutes les lentilles
jusqu'à c'est nous c'est en inuit
oui mais ce que je comprends bien c'est
qu'on vous on vous cantonnent encore oui
dans le rôle de dr dre alors est ce
qu'il ya des solutions ça dépasser ça
moi je vous vois dans n'importe quelle
émission à la télé au cinéma sur scène
je crois que pour sortir de ce de ce
molosse
il faut créer nos propres nos propres
créations faire nos propres choses pour
être vu par nous est proposé ce mélange
est encore à para nord ou d'une certaine
façon oui je crois mais que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui demande qui
captent demande à créon me console
d'après à ce groupe on est passés ont
fait ils font face car en fait c'est un
peu dans cette
c'est un cas comme ça donc pourquoi pas
créer nos propres chambres y est et on a
notre poste de mai comme commises et
c'est quoi ton réalité oui je te tutoie
à celle de la mère et ma grand-mère
immense et quoi s'est jouée au théâtre
de six oui dur ou bien ces deux essais
de jouer dans la pièce des souris des
hommes ne qui va commencer prochainement
chez duceppe
évidemment ça serait de jouer pour un
public québécois
mais mais mais une création autochtone
ou bien d'être un comédien qui est
certes toutes sortes de choi qu'on en
rit oui tout son héros sont des choses
que j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais
pouvoir explorer est ce que c'est
possible je le sais pas encore ce que
les gens sont au rêve oui ça c'est mon
rêve
oui par exemple
mais ce qu'il est possible même si je le
vis très bien ce qu'on est prêt à ouvrir
ses portes sur le plateau et aller vers
ce c'est en noir au cinéma ou à la télé
le jupon moi c est pourquoi nous ici au
québec on joue des exils on pose la
question est-ce que c'est oui je veux
bien les créations s'attendent à voir
emilie monnaies oui j'ai ouï mais aussi
bourrin des autochtones partout oui
lorsqu'elle téléroman à la télévision
oui ça c'est pas c'est pas le rôle d'un
autochtone c'est le rôle de charles
darwin y a quand même si on a vu
on ne vit natacha dans district 9 oui et
puis c'est jouant quelques personnes qui
ont des problèmes mais on peu de savoir
autre chose que les personnes qui ont
des problèmes ça répète sa réputée
gardien qui vient fall qui vient il
vient faire dans ma tâche avec les
prisonniers qui sont olympique qui
partagent un moment de culture je sais
pas avait dit autrement c'est sûr mais
c'est juste des choses des idées comme
ça que sinon oui à tout ça il faut
lancer dans l'élevage
merci charme voilà et on va conclure
l'émission notre émission en live et on
oublie de le dire à nos spectateurs ici
qui sont avec nous qui nous écoutent en
ce moment monsieur gaudreault c'est
cette nuit que ça va se passer c'est une
huile important les politiciens sont
invités oui ce soir donc on est vendredi
19 octobre c'est cette nuit jusqu'à une
heure du matin
les autres voilà oui à montréal c'est à
une heure jusqu'à une heure mais dans
les régions
le dirigeant il ya des régions qui font
tout le tour de l'horloge à montréal ce
à quoi on sait qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens oui ils viennent passer un moment
ça commence au square phillips de 7h30
ya une marche qui va aller jusqu'au
square cabot à 18 heures et toute la
soirée le vent ça s'ouvre avec des
tambours sacrés voient la ressource y
sont présentes là pour parler de leur
travail ou si des kiosques de
sensibilisation pour la population donc
tout le monde est à éviter
d'accord alors c'est ça toute la
population est invitée et puis vous avez
invité évidemment tous les gens
importants qui ont un rôle à jouer sur
l'avenir des sans abri qu'on souhaite ne
plus être décent un prix bientôt est ce
que c'est un faux espoir qu'il faut pas
que ce soit un faux espoir faut qu'on
arrête de constater ce qu'on voit
malheureusement l'an dernier les
ressources ont accueilli davantage de
personnes hommes femmes
on voit un accroissement amis on voit on
en voit de plus en plus sous la
protection de la jeunesse
ceux qui ont des enfants car les gens se
retrouvent à la rue et souvent les gens
sont séparés en femme lorsqu'il
ressources sont pas organisés pour
accueillir des familles on voit
davantage saut en ontario par exemple
des ressources pour famille si on le
peut parfois avoir placé en hôtel ou un
motel donc cet accroissement l'oeil et
pauvres inexorable faut espérer que des
actions près de prévu de fait au niveau
du logement au niveau des services de
santé des services sociaux niveau dans
l'organisation des réseaux de protection
des jeunes est qu'on arrête en avoir des
vecteurs qui crée l'itinérance on it
solutions sont identifiées depuis
longtemps pour l'ensemble population que
les autochtones
c'est les réponses qu'ils manquent l'onu
un nouveau gouvernement
on a quatre ans avec monsieur legault on
a nouvelle ministre la santé pendant mes
cannes qui s'est occupé du réseau de la
santé à moriat et des services sociaux
dont elle est interpellée on l'a évité
aujourd'hui revoir celle et l'homme on a
déjà des contacts avec son cabinet parce
qu'il ya beaucoup à faire
et puisque les autochtones sont
particulièrement concernées dans la rue
la ministre des affaires autochtones du
québec devrait être présente aussi lancé
un appel
oui on espère qu'elle sera là tout comme
d'autres ministres sont responsables du
logement par exemple de la justice parce
que les problématiques qu'on voit quoi
montréal vous déjà des populations
autochtones sont anaïs et une sur
judiciarisation toutes les personnes qui
la rue ont des tic est ce qui fait je
s'ajoute à leur pardon absolu on à
l'insee
organisons par de toulalan travail des
populations autochtones ont davantage
way serait pas si coûteux luxe
les études démontraient que si on les
prenait pour les sortait de la rue ça
coûterait tellement moins cher que de
les laisser dans le rêve et tous les
problèmes de santé fda m'accuser de
l'homme et les soins de santé dont ils
ont besoin définitivement vous avez
raison la judiciarisation hall et les
coûts des systèmes de refuge
l'intervention policière assez des coups
énormes des coups sur les personnes qui
ont un compte sur lui qui se détériore
bien sûr qu'ils deviennent moins en
santé qui pourraient prendre leur place
dans la société et ça peut marcher
quand on leur offre un logement un
accompagnement revenus et quand on
s'assure aussi que la dure dans le temps
parce que sinon ça peut prendre un
goûter pour connaître aux gens le droit
à l'erreur avec des parcours de vie que
l on les personnes mais cela peut
arriver et cela arrive on sort les gens
de la rue malheureusement souvent qu'on
voit l'accroissement de l'impression que
rien ne change c'est un problème des
nouvelles personnes qui arrivent pour
toutes sortes de raisons le comparer du
coût du logement
c'est incroyable que ça existe dans une
société si richard absolument merci à
tous merci à panassac nous allons donc à
les écouter ou réécouter votre reportage
à la provision pour enquêtes mais
surtout votre balade au disponible donc
sur le site de radio canada
les six premières et puis ces
applications balade ou sur le téléphone
voilà chambaud merci beaucoup
alors on garde la surprise pour la
semaine prochaine on voulait se préparer
votre prochain sujet pierre gaudreau
merci infiniment
bonne chance pour la nuit prochaine
espérons qu'ils aient beaucoup de monde
mon avis oui toute la population que ce
soit au québec et surtout à montréal
québec et dans les régions d'aller
participer à cette 29e nuit des sans
abri
voilà merci à vous tous rendez vous la
semaine prochaine vendredi midi 15 pour
un autre facebook live des espaces
autochtone en direct au revoir